yes joe biden has coveted we will talk
about that in a moment but joe biden
also has sort of bigger problems joe
biden's approval has again hit another
record low for the presidency
these are not good numbers and i will
defend
any day
that joe biden is the better choice than
donald trump and that joe biden has made
better decisions than donald trump but i
also can't lie to you and say that the
country is responding super positively
to joe biden his approval rating is
really low uh the average is now down to
37.4 that's an average of recent
approval polls for joe biden 57 percent
of americans now disapprove this is the
most disapproval and least approval of
joe biden
since he became president of the united
states compared to prior presidents you
have to go still all the way back to
truman in the 1940s to find a president
that on month uh i guess it's month 18
of his presidency had an approval this
low you compared to
even trump had a higher approval at this
point in time in his presidency barack
obama george w bush way way better than
biden at this point bill clinton george
h.w bush ronald reagan uh jimmy carter
gerald ford john f kennedy dwight d
eisenhower you indeed have to go
all the way back to harry truman
in uh what would have been 1946
to find a president with a lower
approval
18 months in than joe biden
and part of what is going on is the
feeling and it is not an altogether
incorrect feeling that not enough is
happening that there are not enough
accomplishments and we talked yesterday
on the bonus show about the new idea to
get something done on climate for joe
biden is to do some executive orders and
the executive orders are sort of like
okay
but
they're not great
and uh the good news for joe biden is
that if we continue to
believe this notion that it's the
economy stupid that what the public
uses as a proxy to whether the president
is doing a good job
is the economy
and every indication is that inflation
has peaked and that the july numbers
which will be out in in mid-august will
be
lower inflation gas prices have now been
declining for
uh something like uh a month or more let
me look at exactly when
the june 14th was the peak and it is now
july 22nd so so basically five plus
weeks gas prices have been declining and
quite precipitously so
if that continues to go in that
direction if the stock market steadies
as it has shown some signs of doing it's
likely that joe biden's approval will
improve but it is currently not good if
you looked at the betting markets who do
you think will win the presidential
nomination for the democrats in 2024 not
who do you plan to support who do you
not who do you like who do you think
will win
joe biden's chances in the betting
markets are again
declining
and gavin newsom is there in second
place right alongside kamala harris and
the margin right now let's put it a
different way
more people believe
that either
gavin newsom or kamala harris will be
the 2024 nominee than the number that
believe it will be biden individually
biden still has a plurality but combined
people believe it will be newsom or
harris more than they believe it will be
joe biden so remains to be seen we're
watching that we're watching polling
we're watching accomplishments and of
course we're also tracking joe biden's
health uh as he does indeed have covered
with reportedly mild symptoms let's talk
about that next
you knew they were going to do it you
knew that when joe biden got covered the
anti-vaxx was going to come out of the
woodwork
the
glee about biden having coveted was
going to come out of the woodwork and
conspiracy theories we're going to come
out of the woodwork and we have all of
it for you today let's start with a fox
news contributor
saying that joe biden
got covered as karma for pretending to
have cancer now this is stupid for two
reasons number one biden didn't pretend
to have cancer and number two
biden already had coveted before
he made the cancer gaffe
by all
reasonable understandings of the
incubation period of covet so let's look
at this clip and then discuss i hate to
be that annoyingly optimistic guy
there's no better time in the world to
be sick than right now today right in
history because we have more opportunity
to heal from it now than we've ever had
and there's no better place than
probably the white house uh to be when
you get sick i mean you have all the
resources in front of you
my experience with kova the twice the
two times i've had it
have the first time i had a little bit
of a fever the second time i had a cold
and i think that's what everyone has
been saying over and over again uh so i
hope well not everyone not the million
people that died but yes many many many
people have mild symptoms and that's
true and pray that that's what the
president experiences i don't want any
bad health on him i think life comes at
you fast i think when you're pretending
to have cancer one day and you've got
covered the next you might want to
recalibrate how you treat things and how
you talk um but i'm not gonna you know i
don't wish bad luck on him and i'm not
gonna say that that that's reason why
it's just maybe it's a good opportunity
for him to have a reality check i get so
frustrated with these politicians that
think they have to connect themselves to
every dire thing that happens in an
american's life and i think president uh
biden uh his little statement on cancer
yesterday just his proof of that that
paul citizens have taken that too far so
what i hope is he recovers fast it
doesn't hurt him that well uh that much
at all and then when he recovers he
reconsiders
you know just how politicians work on
stuff like this because saying he had
cancer the way he did and backtracking
it the way they did that's karma man you
don't want to it's karma man he just
misspoke guys i mean this is very very
stupid as a reminder yesterday when
speaking joe biden talked about
have cancer rather than had cancer he's
not pretending to have cancer i mean
to pretend to have cancer you'd have to
be able to say
i have this type of cancer and it's a
lie he just misspoke my mother drove us
and rather than us be able to walk and
guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
you had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i have so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation all right so he just misspoke
and then the other thing that it's some
kind of karma because biden pretended to
have cancer
uh typically it's at least two days of
incubation with covid and it was
announced very early thursday morning
biden making the cancer gaffe on
wednesday afternoon the idea that the
timing even works doesn't work these
people are very very strange and they
have extraordinarily bizarre ideas but
not as bizarre as the ones i'm going to
show you next
let's now look at around
around the country so to speak a tour of
right wing media reactions more
reactions to joe biden's covet diagnosis
we will start with oan this is one
american news anchor alison steinberg
gleefully reporting that president joe
biden has coveted and asking her
followers to weigh in to predict
is he gonna die
well what do you know double back double
boosted fight and just got coven what do
you think is gonna happen will you come
back and say he's so glad he got the
shots because it could have been much
worse or do you think he's gonna
let me know your thoughts down below
yeah when she says do you think he's
gonna she does kind of like the
uh neck slice motion
um i don't know if that's some kind of
strange filter by the way on this
individual unclear so that's on oan
allison steinberg gleeful about it then
we go over to newsmax where a newsmax
guest wishes biden the best
but
but i wish him the best but so again
speedy recovery we wish him the best but
i think it's time that we really refocus
on some of the issues that we have here
at home and in our backyards before we
go down the path of another double
booster and you know vaccines for kids
under five aren't those issues in our
backyard like that's very strange we
should focus on domestic issues rather
than things like whether americans get
coveted in america
sounds like a domestic issue ma'am
uh we i wish him the best but
i'm against racism but
i'm against the n-word but
um and then on fox news here's another
idea
joe biden actually had coveted last
friday when he was in jerusalem or as
donald trump used to call it jerusalem
and uh
that this is harris faulkner's idea
kovid i'm harris faulkner you were in
the faulkner focus the white house has
said that he is experiencing what they
are calling mild symptoms
he's now
in isolation
the president has referenced his help
during his recent visit to jerusalem in
his own words let's watch right
i
was making a speech
and
i had a terrible head of hair
excuse me a terrible headache
and uh
i'm sorry
i had a terrible headache
this is years ago
and i did a very stupid thing
[Music]
so again the president's struggling a
bit there we do know the white house
doctors the white house has announced uh
that they do not believe his symptoms
from covid began before
yesterday that was last friday what we
showed you
just for perspective
that's perspective in the faulkner focus
on fox news
uh i mean listen the timing of it
suggests that he probably didn't have
covid last friday um i'm guessing that
with a cough like that he would be
tested
it doesn't really make sense the timing
of it doesn't really make sense by the
way it does bear mentioning that we know
donald trump knew he had coveted during
that presidential debate with joe biden
and he found a way to not have to test
at the venue to just show up and say i
had a negative test
and um that's crazy that's completely
and totally nuts so there was no mention
of that by fox news at the time but
here's a story that they will gladly
speculate on even if it doesn't really
make too much sense so
basically as expected reporting on
biden's covet diagnosis anti-vaxx
glee
uh speculation about whether he will die
conspiracies about karma and pretending
to have cancer just about everything you
could imagine
we have the next david pakman show
viewer town hall coming up tuesday july
26th at 6 pm eastern
everyone's welcome to call in we will
open the phone lines via discord
and i will just take questions question
after question after question it will be
streaming live on the pacman live
youtube channel that's the other youtube
channel
youtube.compacmanlive i hope you'll be
there
and i also hope that you'll sign up at
joinpakman.com and become a member when
you are a member
you get a priority phone line to call
into the town halls which is
i would say a beautiful thing you can
use the coupon code obamana
to get a discount off of your membership
at joinpakman.com we'll take a quick
break
great to see you here on this friday
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpacman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
the david pakman show is a community
funded program you can sign up at
joinpackman.com it's the place to do it
and you can use the coupon code big
voting 22 for a discount off of the cost
of a membership you'll of course get the
world famous award-winning bonus show i
believe the top david pakman show bonus
show probably in the world
and so many other great things sign up
at joinpakman.com let's now speak to
people from the audience yes there is an
audience without that audience i'm a guy
in a room with a microphone and that's
sad
uh you can use discord to get in touch
with me that's davidpakman.com
discord let's start today with elias
from fort worth elias welcome what's
going on
um
should people make an effort to say
correctly hard to pronounce names
so for example
um i don't want to correct you but you
said my name wrong it's elias like the
spanish way so
yes people should make such an effort
all right thank you no problem take care
uh
okay
here we go
let's let's go next
to um
[Music]
let's go to paul garcia from mexico
paul welcome
all right can you hear me yes i can
oh okay uh we've been uh you've been
talking about uh
how abortion and
gun control can
activate democrats boat do you think a
trump associate indictment can
activate republicans to vote
you know maybe to some degree but not
really in the sense that when it comes
to the gun safety issue and roe v wade
and democrats being activated
it's because democrats want to change
those things by voting for different
people
although certainly there will be
trumpists who
might hear oh this trump associate was
indicted or whatever um who are they
going to vote for i mean it's like
voting for your local
member of congress isn't really going to
do anything related to that in any kind
of direct way
so i don't think it will engage and and
kind of involve people and excite them
in the same way no
do you think in like a
texas where the
the republican governor is really
dumb and
you know everything is it's going the
wrong way do you think we're going to
see a big change
like blue wave
i think there's no evidence
right now that that's what's going to
happen i mean you did see you know if
you look at biden versus trump in texas
in 2020 it was the closest margin
for a presidential race
in texas for a while i don't remember
exactly when but but for a while
and so i do think texas is becoming more
purple but i don't expect to blew any
overwhelming blue wave in texas in the
next few years no
okay no thank you
all right no problem there's paul from
mexico good uh good question i
appreciate that
let's go next to
where do we want to go there's so many
people who want to be on let's go to
saigon mike saigon mike you're next
saigon mike
you're unmuted but i'm wondering if you
have the wrong audio device selected
and last chance for saigon mike to fix
your audio
all right that's too bad saigon mike is
gone let's go next to steve from chicago
steve welcome
hey david can you hear me yes i can
um yes so i was wondering i know we've
been kind of talking about uh you
brought joe rogan a little bit ago and
he said when he brought up um
his liking for desantis and you kind of
brought up he maybe doesn't really know
what he's talking about but do you think
the possibility maybe
that he sees more in line even though he
is a progressive
he sees more in line with some of the
stuff that um
desantis is doing and isn't really happy
with uh some of the stuff that like uh
denver kind of presidents are doing like
with biden
uh no that sounds weird to me i mean if
if rogan
is more progressive
he couldn't possibly like what desantis
is doing
if he knows what desantis is doing
but i i uh but all i'm saying is that
the way that the
he he can still be progressive but not
like the that things that the democratic
party is going too far and that desantis
would be that the xanthus and people
like the scientists might isn't as far
right as they're actually saying or as
extreme well i mean you're saying is it
possible that something rogan hasn't
said is what's in his head and it's like
i guess so but we have no reason to
think that that's what rogan thinks it's
sort of like mind reading you know
no no like i guess an
example
for me is that the whole the way that
the progressive movement has been going
with uh trying to
push like uh puberty blockers on
children and the trans athletes which is
like i know a subject that
uh joe rogan opposes what the way that's
going and that someone may be on the
right
that
would be more open to his view of like
how the that that should be uh played
i'm not aware of
the movement among progressives to push
puberty blockers on kids can you tell me
more about that
uh
wasn't the
health secretary literally out there
saying that
the kids should be able to transition
and use puberty for lockers
if they feel like they're in the wrong
body
oh uh okay because first you said that
there were there was a movement pushing
puberty blockers on kids it sounds like
what you're saying is
one biden administration official said
that for the tiny percentage of people
in that situation and the subsection
within that that wants to pursue such
drugs that it should be possible is that
what you're what you actually
meant um i mean
the first thing you said was that
progressives are pushing puberty
blockers on kids but then your example
wasn't that was it
i mean
okay pushing the idea of using
puberty blockers on kids if you want to
be more
straightforward about it well when you
say that it sounds like you're saying
that there's a movement to just convince
children to take puberty blockers but
there isn't any movement like that is
there
um
it seems there's a movement
i would say so okay so who is going
around saying hey what we want is we
want more kids to take puberty blockers
who's saying that
uh
the biden administration for kids who
want to take puberty blockers
oh but so what you're saying is the
biden administration
has a position that
in certain situations for the tiny
percentage of kids who identify as being
in the wrong body for lack of a better
term
and for whom
medical professionals believe it would
be appropriate to make that decision
it should be a decision they are allowed
to make right because that's very
different than they are pushing puberty
blockers on kids
uh i would say
anyone like i guess the well let me give
you an example to make it really clear
oh what i guess let me let me let me let
me clarify i guess from my spot for you
give your example sorry i'm going to
interrupt you just so you can get your
comeback um so i guess from joe rogan's
perspective is that the kid like a kid
that age let's just say
five six younger than that
like we they can't they can't enter into
contracts they can't do other stuff
because they don't have the mental
capacity to actually understand yep if
they're it maybe would be in the wrong
body or not in the wrong body
or anything like that and i'm not
talking about adults or anything i'm
talking about kids got it that it would
be it and the harmful effects they could
have on puberty backers with them and
their mind not being able to fully
understand what's going on would you
apply that same logic to children
getting vaccines where the kids can't
actually consent themselves the parents
are doing it for them and they don't
understand the full impact of those and
once you do it you can't undo the fact
that you've gotten a vaccine would you
apply the same standard to the vaccines
i'm curious
uh
vaccines um
it's very
interest um
no i guess i
i wouldn't but i guess i would i guess
the i said under i guess i'm going back
to like
do
kids actually understand i think i can
understand more of a vaccine if they're
if the parent talks about them talks
about it to them so it sounds like
you're saying it's actually not about
whether the kids can or can't sign
contracts or are of legal age it's
whether they can understand a concept
based on what their parents tell them
that's the standard you're now laying
out
no i'm not i'm not saying there's a
stand i'm just saying that
forcing
oh my standard is right i i don't think
i i i i don't think kids
understand exactly what they're doing
with the the puberty blockers and more
of the long-term effects that could have
on them
versus like a vaccine i guess which is
which is different i mean look i'm sure
but like my in a few in a few weeks my
daughter will be due for vaccines she
can't understand them and no matter how
i explain it to her she's not going to
understand them by your standard about
understanding i shouldn't be allowed to
get her vaccinated right
i'm not saying i'm not saying i don't
think she'd be allowed to uh get her
vaccinated i'm not right what i'm asking
you is you said the standard that makes
vaccines different than puberty blockers
is
the kids better understand vaccines
rather than their understanding of
puberty blockers i just explained my
daughter doesn't understand vaccines at
all should by your standard
she should not i should not be able to
get her vaccinated in a couple weeks
based on your standard
i didn't say that was a standard of mine
i was saying no i literally asked you
what's your standard and you said that's
your standard my standard is they can't
understand it
not on vaccines i guess i say i was
saying my understanding would be
able to explain vaccines versus puberty
blockers and the whole and all the side
effects moving forward transitioning and
everything like that i mean okay i
i'm but again i'm basically i'm what was
my basic question is
my base my basic going back to the joe
rogan part was yeah more under uh and
i'm not i guess i don't know why i guess
my pushing
is uh i'm not saying they're just like
going up and giving up kids puberty
blockers but more of the emphasis on
transitioning younger kids when it when
the long-term effects
they probably won't be able to
understand what's actually going on with
their body got it so let's so let's say
let's now drill down to what we are
talking about so
you're not saying
that they are let's go just follow me
step by step you're not saying anyone is
forcing puberty blockers physically into
children right you're not making the
claim anybody's doing that no that came
across that way that's not true no no
i'm not saying it i'm just i'm let me
clear up so you're not saying anyone is
forcibly being given puberty blockers
good second is there any campaign to go
out and say hey kids
consider puberty blockers it's cool like
is there a pr campaign or you're saying
there isn't that either
um i wouldn't say there's a pr campaign
to like say it's cool but i think
there's a
campaign slash strategy of movement of
like putting more of a
uh
spotlight on them
for younger for younger kids basically
in
uh
with
doctors schools the within the
administration everything so you're
saying that there are schools where they
do presentations and then go hey kids if
you're not feeling good about your body
how about puberty blockers that's
happening somewhere
i wouldn't say that they would say pure
blockers in there but say
within schools they're trying they're
more or less i guess going into like uh
gender identity
and everything sexuality and everything
like that which would would bring the
conversation moving towards that do you
have any evidence that in schools where
they talk about the fact that trans
people exist they're pushing puberty
blockers is there a single example of
such a school
um i mean wait do like the example where
they're mentioning puberty blockers in
like the like the teachers said the word
puberty blockers yeah where they're
saying not when when issues of gender
are taught in schools
where puberty blockers are being talked
about by teachers and presented as
something to pursue or something you
said remember that at the beginning of
the call you said pushing the word was
pushing i'm looking for someone so
i'm not saying again i like i said i
don't think that they're like the
teachers themselves are saying
uh are pushing
puberty blocker like they're going in
the same puberty blockers i'm saying
that the conver like the thought process
and the the transition to the end result
with transitioning puberty rockers is in
like um
you may not like pushing the whole idea
again i'm not i if adult wants to make a
decision i'm not against anything at all
i'm saying kids specifically pushing
ideas
but you you started the call by saying
that something is being pushed and we've
gone piece by piece and you're
acknowledging you can't actually
identify anyone pushing it
i mean everyone i ask you is this person
pushing it is that person pushing it you
go well no so now you're saying i'm not
even saying
what is your definition of pushing it
promoting encouraging
yeah i mean the bible administration is
encouraging kids
okay no but no steve now we're back to
the beginning that was your first claim
which already fell apart all right steve
thank you for the call i'm gonna let you
go by the way i'm not even taking a
position
for or against puberty blockers for kids
like i don't know enough about it to say
maybe it's not a good idea maybe i'm not
taking a position
that caller had no idea what he was
talking about okay
let's go next to jim from chattanooga
jim welcome
hi david a long time uh viewer how are
you doing doing well
uh i guess my question is how to reframe
uh kind of basically the basic idea is
there's going to be pain and i think
democrats are struggling with this
basically a lot of the problems are
right now that we're suffering from are
from taking the can down the road
and a lot of the solutions tend to have
short-term sacrifice involved how do we
reframe that so people that are in their
60s who will never enjoy
a working universal health care system
are willing to wake that sacrifice
well this isn't really like a new thing
that humans do i mean i think for most
humans with a normal uh
emotional
landscape
the idea that we might do something
that's good for
the species we belong to even if i won't
personally benefit from it is still a
completely reasonable thing to do i mean
you know the interstate highway system
took a very long time to build and many
of the people that supported their tax
dollars going to it didn't live long
enough to enjoy it and i i mean it's
right it doesn't seem i think the weird
thing to me isn't
why the weird thing to me would be that
more people wouldn't of course
understand that the way things are the
way the some of the good things we have
today we have because people who didn't
benefit from them were okay supporting
them financially and that as a result we
should do the same thing to keep
improving society it would be
if we have to explain that to people
then we're in real trouble
so you don't think the attitude around
that has changed i think that it hasn't
changed
in terms of
people's emotional understanding of it
but i do think that the
the political system we have
including these terms of two four and
six years that don't really encourage
long-term thinking they encourage what
can i do to justify my next reelection
that definitely is not good
right and i think that's just a
feature yes
yeah absolutely
thank you david all right thank you
maybe just one more thing i'm getting a
vasectomy next week and i thought maybe
you could
comment on that i'm 36 no kids
um that's interesting you know most many
many urologists won't do a no kids
vasectomy for people your age how what
was the conversation like
well i found one in georgia so i'll be
traveling oh so you're admitting it was
hard to find one you have you had to go
to find up one in a different place
not just find one they would find one
that's affordable like under two
thousand dollars it's not just it
if you don't have money you can't just
go i don't know people think that these
things are just out there to go grab the
off the shelf somewhere but did you talk
to
urologists who said you know for someone
in your situation i don't really do
vasectomies you don't have kids you're
only 36.
i honestly didn't even look here in
tennessee because i didn't want to deal
with it oh okay
all right good well so why are you doing
you're just very sure you never want to
have kids
well and i live in tennessee i mean
i don't want to be forced into
fatherhood sorry i just don't
okay what do you mean by that
well i think we had a tracker law here
so when roe was overturned i think it's
six weeks now it might be six weeks but
it may oh i see what you're trenching
from there
any thought to maybe freezing sperm so
you have the option
ah
no there's probably there's probably a
little couple little jimmies floating
out there somewhere they can you know
i'm just kidding david i'm just kidding
no i i haven't considered that okay all
right very good jim thank you good luck
with the procedure
i love you david all right take care i
love you buddy okay we're going to take
a quick break if you're holding don't
hang up we are going back to the phones
on what has been an eventful day an
eventful day standby right back to the
phones in a moment
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies
mugs and t-shirts you can support the
show for as little as two dollars a
month check it out at patreon.com
david pakman show let's go back to
discord and hear from a few more people
uh davidpakman.com
discord is the place to be
let's go to scott from scotland who is
scottish welcome scott
scottish scott from scotland you are
self-muted unmute yourself please in
order to be able to talk to me you have
muted yourself locally
please unmute yourself so that we can
talk
and final chance for scottish scott from
scotland to unmute yourself i've unmuted
you you do need to unmute yourself to be
able
to talk to me
i would love to to hear whether scottish
scott from scotland even really has a
scottish accent but
can't seem to get it all technically
happening and scott is gone that's too
bad all right let's go go to our friend
john paul jones john paul jones welcome
back
um hey david thank you for having me on
i have three questions and
and
apology too so my first question is have
you uh have you been thinking about
going on crystal kyle and friends
second question
i want to ask as there was an argument
where there's about a month and a half
ago about how biden doesn't think he has
enough friends
for vader and in the war ukraine i have
if you're biting shields what offline
would you be willing to give putin
and third i
i started i started with a progressive
blog about three months ago i've already
posted my first two articles if i were
to send them to you on twitter would you
be willing to read them and finally i
just wanted to apologize for my behavior
in the previous two calls i understand i
haven't been
the best caller oh my god i don't so
let's see so let's go reverse order i
don't remember your previous calls so no
need to apologize two if you send me a
articles on twitter i can't even look at
my twitter feed it's so over it's so
overloaded so i basically just look at
the verified feed i know that that's
very elitist of me but i just it's it's
impossible to see anything i get so many
messages and i'm honestly just too busy
to be reviewing other people's projects
right now number two um if i was on in
hold on if i was in biden's shoes i
guess going in reverse order we're now
at number three but
if i was in biden's shoes what sort of
an off-ramp could i imagine for putin
i've talked about this before it's
probably something where he gets to stay
in some of the regions he's already in
like the donetsk and luhansk or
something i don't know i mean i don't
love saying that but it's probably the
type of off-ramp that he needs and then
what was the first question
have you been thinking about going on
crystal kyle's friends oh no no i mean
listen i i can't it's not i they would
have to invite me it's not have i been
thinking it's not it's not up to me
they'd have to invite me you know
okay um well i mean do you know of any
other progressive youtubers that i could
that could offer me some advice
advice what would you you want advice
from progressive youtubers
i'm i'm starting a progressive blog
you know rather than look for i would
just start the blog just start the blog
and grow the blog rather than getting
advice from people the the advice is
just do it do it as well as you possibly
can if you build it they will come
okay well
um thank you david um i just want to let
you can i just let you know
let you know um and know who i'm named
after i'm guessing you're named after
the basis for led zeppelin right i mean
john paul jones
actually
no the thing i'm actually named after um
my name comes from the founder of the
american navy's john paul jones got it
okay
all right thank you john paul
okay well once again i'm sorry for my
previous two calls apology unnecessary i
have no memory of the calls there is
john paul jones what a phone call
let's go next i'm told that scottish
scott from scotland has fixed his
problems
scottish scott you're back what's going
on
hey david can you hear me yes i
can oh fantastic yeah sorry about that i
just uh saw your video on youtube and so
i had to download this card again and
uh get off and running and yeah i wasn't
quite used to getting it to work and
didn't know how to unmute myself are you
sure you're really scottish
what makes you say that no i'm kidding
i'm kidding go ahead what's on your mind
now obviously um
yeah i'm just really looking forward to
the
uh the final hearing of the january 6th
committee tomorrow i just wondered what
you're thinking in anticipation of like
who's going to be there what sort of uh
testimony we might expect and how the
trump is at large might
sort of respond to it well unfortunately
because this is the friday show that
hearing was last night and i know that
you've been in a coma for 48 hours so
you wouldn't know that
but um i believe what happened slash is
expected is that uh donald trump's
former deputy national security adviser
will testify
donald trump's attorney a white house
attorney pat sipoloni is expected slash
did testify uh i i am looking forward to
slash really enjoyed it last night if
you understand what i'm saying
uh yeah yes um let's just say that all
the
tv wires melted yesterday due to all the
things that we're experiencing in the uk
just like well anyway isn't it like
three days earlier in scotland or
something like that
three days earlier yeah that's why you
just haven't gotten the hearing yet
uh yeah yeah we're actually time
traveling i can see into your future
see and
you made a video earlier about the um
what was it again the the
reaction from trump supporters if he
actually does become indicted by merrick
garland or whomever um
and
if i remember correctly you thought that
the there could potentially be among his
strongest cult followers uh a really
strong violent reaction
yes i i'm not so sure i think
i think yes there will be a certain
violent reaction but in terms of like
mass protests of thousands of people all
gathering together i just get the
impression that a they're too
shattered and shrapnel i should say at
the moment and they're just too far
spread and
they can't organize themselves well
enough and b
i don't know just do you think they're
that far gone that
if
he were to be indicted
people would see that as
oh they're they're lying it's fake news
etc or would that almost be like a
wake-up call for a lot of his uh
no the cultists would say that it's all
a political witch-hunt they they would
say this is an outrage and we i think
you're right they wouldn't do like mass
peaceful protests you would just have
these small violent cells going
completely berserk uh scott i i gotta
run i appreciate the call and hearing
about all of it
let's see if we can chat with a couple
of other people how about connor from
atlanta georgia connor welcome
how you doing david i'm doing well
awesome um
so
i wanted to ask exactly um
about biden running in 2024 for a second
term
um
if if uh
people who um because i'm more of a
centrist i don't really
um i'm a little conflicted about the
2024 election right now because i guess
the running up for
the republicans are um
as ron desantis i don't think trump
stands a chance running again
um i don't know if
biden would be good enough for a second
term just simply because of his
cognitive ability currently
um so what exactly do you think on that
because i don't i don't know if um i
just don't i'm just very conflicted
right now for 2024. well listen
speculations about cognitive ability
aside i just don't think joe biden's
running in 2024. he's i don't think he's
interested in it um i think he would
have a very tough time winning
he'll be 82
i just i just don't think he's going to
run and i know people say but david he
keeps saying his intention is to run
yeah i know his intention is to run and
i don't think he's going to do it so i
don't think you're going to end up in a
situation quite frankly where you'll
have to
figure out how you feel about joe
biden's cognition i think he's just not
going to be a candidate
well who do you think should be the
running up then
listen i think there's a lot of people a
lot of rising stars in the democratic
party we've talked about gavin newsom's
political skill i've mentioned i really
like jamie raskin i like stacy abrams i
like john ossoff i think pete budege
would do
really well now that he has more name
recognition maybe not right away maybe
it's we've got to wait another cycle or
two for him but i think there's a lot of
really smart people who would be
good in terms of the performance piece
of what it takes to be president
what about uh um it's funny you
mentioned john ossoff and stay favorite
stacey abrams because i do live in
georgia
um what do you think of uh warnock
yeah i mean i think that his his
demeanor
i i love him personally i think that
something about his demeanor maybe seems
like a less obvious win
compared to some of the other people i
mentioned uh but he he's very skilled i
just don't think he's yet as skilled
politically as some of the other folks i
mentioned
right right do you think we should get a
um a democratic president in there who's
um religious because rafael warnock
comes from a religious background yeah i
mean um
listen i don't i don't know at this
point whether that really matters
you sort of have to play to religiosity
but i don't think you have to pretend to
be deeply religious necessarily it just
has to be plausible that you like you
follow a religion
i think it's going to be less and less
of an issue over time although still for
the evangelical voters in particular it
really does matter
right right okay i see
well that's all i needed david thank you
all right thanks connor very much
appreciate that all right everybody
that's going to do it for today
we don't have time for more calls today
but we will in the future and i hope to
hear from people next time thank you for
joining me we'll take a quick break and
be right back
follow us on social media interact with
the david pakman show community see
exclusive content see when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
big show announcements we post daily
find us on reddit twitter instagram
facebook discord and tick tock
all right it is time for the friday
mailbag you can email info
davidpakman.com if you have something
you'd like to say ask complaint whatever
the case may be also anytime you post on
youtube or reply to us on twitter or
whatever it might end up featured in the
mail bag you just never know but let's
get into the first one colin wrote in
with a beautiful anti-semitic conspiracy
theory colin wrote in about the causer
influence in u.s politics saying david
if you really had any intake intention
of being a good american patriot please
check out your relatives dealings in u.s
politics
obviously you won't and dare not that's
colin now this is something called the
kazar myth
this is an anti-semitic trope
it has been largely abandoned although
some really hardcore anti-semites still
talk about it the idea is that ashkenazi
jews like me whose lineage goes to
eastern europe
that are our lineage is basically fake
and that we i really descended from
kazars who are a multi-ethnic
turkic peoples
semi-nomadic and blah blah blah
basically the idea is even the people we
claim to be
is a lie this has been extraordinarily
widely debunked it's nonsense uh only
the most hardcore anti-semites still
push it but that's colin and we do have
some of them in our audience that's for
sure
rob wrote in and says david sir the new
haircut looks
spectacular when you go to your stylist
what exactly do you ask for love the
show keep up the good work that's rob in
cincinnati well listen rob i've been
going to the same uh hairdresser for
over a decade
so at this point
she says
same thing just shorter i go yep same
thing we've been doing and then that's
really it but if i had to start from
scratch i think what i would say is
uh i part my hair on this side i want
scissors all around no no buzzers or
clippers other than for the sideburns
and you know the back of my neck um and
just kind of this is this is the shape
or maybe i would even take a screenshot
of my show
and say this is the haircut i'm looking
for i think that's the best advice i can
offer
alex wrote in about people making guns
at home
a recent horrible shooting
guns were made at home
and alex says hey david i just heard
your good point about people making guns
at home however this got me thinking
about how absurd this situation is for
example
terrorists make their bombs at home so
should bombs be legal because we can't
stop literally all bomb attacks should
theft be legal because we can't stop all
thieves should murder be legal because
we can't catch all murderers mitigation
and deterrent are words that exist yeah
on the entire so after the shooting
where the i don't even remember which
one it was because there's so many
was it the july fourth one where the gun
the guns were made were made at home
okay
um you had some people on the right the
pro-gun people saying this is why gun
control does nothing
you can't stop people
if they're really determined from
getting guns they can just make them at
home and of course the reaction is oh
and i'm sorry it was the japanese
shooting the japanese shooting the
assassination of former prime minister
shinzo abe and the thing was you can
barely buy guns in japan but they just
made them at home
if in the united states
every would-be shooter and i'm talking
about
individual homicides mass shootings and
suicides if every would-be shooter in
the united states
could only get access to a firearm by
making it at home
the number of shootings would go down
dramatically
dramatically i know what you're saying
well but you could make the gun at home
yes
most people don't know how to do it
many who could research it to figure it
out would say that's too much work i
don't want to do that and the number of
people who would be dissuaded from
shooting anyone if they had to make
their gun at home
uh is an incredible number
and sure somebody will make their gun at
home i understand but the whole point as
alex points out here is mitigation and
deterrent and if you had to make a gun
in order to shoot someone
uh
number of shootings goes down
dramatically
dustin says
about my um
commentary on jesse lee peterson
being homophobic
but also being gay dustin says lethal
takedown and all totally true
however
you end the clip by saying you're
uncomfortable with peterson's role as a
counselor to young men the implication
is your discomfort storms stems from him
being gay i don't think this matches
your values and it's a terrible thing to
imply that is not at all what i meant
the reason i'm uncomfortable with jessie
lee peterson mentoring young men
is because he does this thing that many
in the religious community do which is
they're not therapists they're
completely unlicensed to be in that role
but they loosely use the term counseling
sometimes they use coaching
that's what i have a problem with
not the fact that he's gay and in
general the type of i mean listen he was
doing anti-gay christian counseling i'm
against anti-gay christian counseling
whether the counselor
is gay or straight okay so dustin please
don't attribute to me things that i very
clearly didn't say
eric wrote in and said tell the truth
pacman biden's inflation caused a
recession as consumers tightened their
belts people react to high prices by
cutting back on food and travel this
news is nothing to celebrate
uh there is no evidence of that
there's no evidence of that if you
believe that the coveted stimulus that
biden did caused inflation
then you've got to blame trump doubly
because trump had two of those
packages of stimuli
um
packages of stimulus i guess it would be
and also we're seeing the inflation
globally
so um
this is just a completely baseless claim
and there's a lot of them floating
around people aren't limited
by the facts when they make claims
basic dad
says why doesn't pacman simply move to
venezuela
where can live in peace and harmony with
those who agree with his socialist
viewpoint does do you think this person
knows a damn thing about me
number one i'm not a socialist
number two
i don't like the chavez maduro regime of
venezuela i think they're terrible in
fact there's people in my audience who
love the regime and are mad at me that i
don't like it
i think that it's a disastrous regime
uh that has
eliminated the independence of courts
and in some cases media that has raped
and pillaged the country's resources for
their gain not that of its population i
think that they're horrible so maybe
someone who likes venezuela and is a
socialist wants to move there
but i'm good basic dad thank you clown
rhoden
clown says i'm going to issue a dire
warning to musk pacman and all of
trump's critics out there if you do not
want to go to prison or a re-education
camp i would refrain from any more
criticism of donald trump i say this
because there's a very good chance that
he can become president again and with
the way the country is going i truly
believe trump is going to be hell-bent
on revenge for his enemies
i know that may sound absolutely insane
but it is very plausible that something
like that could easily happen if trump
gets back into the white house anyone
who was speaking in a negative way
against trump i believe
i believe
will be imprisoned and sent to a camp
so here's my thought clown
i don't deny for a second
that trump would love to do that
if he became president again but i don't
think he's going to
i think he uh will fail to do that
but your sense of the instincts trump
would have
i can't disagree with
last one today is from john john says i
see mr pacman playing the victim
mr pakman trolls every trump rally
but when someone trolls him he has to
make a deal about it i wonder why mr
pakman didn't troll 2 000 mules for only
30 seconds actually we looked at like 15
minutes of 2000 mules it's a joke
two thousand meals trolls itself i don't
even really have to do anything
john goes on mr pakman's narrative is
getting destroyed as americans are more
concerned with the inflation and gas
prices and the terrible rise in crime in
mostly all the
democrat-runned
areas
democrat-runned areas we've talked about
inflation
gas prices are coming down quite quickly
uh
crime in democratic cities you know
crime is in cities cities tend to be
democratic safe cities are run by
democrats less safe cities are run by
democrats it's a very old trope and also
important by crime rate
the crime rates are often high
in rural and suburban conservative areas
but
narrative right that definitely
gets in the way of a good narrative
send in your messages info
davidpakman.com
they may be used on a future show and
remember that tuesday july 26th at 6 pm
eastern
is the next david pakman show viewer
town hall we'll stream live on pacman
live
hope to see you there and we'll see you
on today's bonus show
you